he's Jordy Nelson of the Packers they
had a win yesterday against the the
Texans next up will be the Seahawks
Jordy joins us now what was it like
playing in the snow that for us to watch
is great but to play in it is it ain't
fun oh it's a lot of work to constantly
try to stay dry keep the hands dry the
officials keeping the balls dry and then
into the second half it seemed like the
snow really started accumulating on the
bottom of our clits so in between every
play we're bringing our cleats together
trying to keep the spikes clean so we
get up traction so it was a it was a
little different I think it's the first
game I've had that's been a full snow
game like that I've had a couple work
maybe start snowing in the fourth
quarter and those are little better
because hopefully you got a nice lead
and then you can enjoy the snow fall and
have fun at the end but there's a battle
and uh you know we'll just take the win
in a move on but I look like I'm
watching the game with Rodney Harrison
and Tony Dungy and they thought the
Texans did not have the right shoes and
the defensive back fell down trying to
cover you when you had the touchdown but
is there any truth to that do you even
know I don't know I mean I know he fell
down but I don't know what cleats
they're aware i'm sure they have access
to all the shoes i mean seven studs or
the molded or whatever they want so that
is one advantage of playing up here
throughout the years and obviously being
at home is we know what what works best
and they kind of have to adjust on the
fly if they want or you know them it
might take too much time for them to do
it get it done but i don't want to
offend you i hope i didn't that the only
way you got a touchdown is if the
defensive back fell down Jordy did I did
I offend you you didn't and I'll take it
is not gonna bother Raider when you're
looking at playing these games now in
the importance of these games now you
guys have to be in playoff mode i would
imagine it what what kind of feeling is
it for these games that you can't afford
any slip-up because the lines keep
winning absolutely we know we put
ourselves in the situation by the way we
played earlier in the year and it's just
so why it is so we've taken a week by
week but we understand that every game
is extremely important
even if we went out we still need help
so we can't give one back and ask for
more help so it's one of those things
that we got locked in each week make
sure we prepare we got tough one coming
up Sunday against Seattle but you know
it's one of those things that it kind of
put you in that playoff mode and we were
there a few years ago won the superbowl
had to went out but this is a few more
games and what that was but off maybe
you'll just allow us to build some
momentum and make a run in it also from
afar we keep hearing it looks like
you're getting your legs back you'll
hear the announcer I don't know what
that means Stewart e so our are you
getting your legs back after surgery um
I think what it means is a week to week
thing that if I have a really good game
like that if I don't and I've kind of
lost the steps so um this week my legs
were back we'll see what happens next
week again do you if you like the
challenge with Seattle you know it's
gonna be physical you know they're going
to talk although Earl Thomas is done for
the year with the broken leg but do you
look forward to Seattle more than
somebody else I don't know if you look
forward to it more I think it's a fun
challenge and it's one of those things
that obviously they've had a great
defense for the four years we've had
some great matchups against them
obviously some big games and it's a
great challenge so if you want to when
you play this game you want to go
against the best and obviously they have
a lot of great difference of players
that will create some great challenges
for us so it'll be a battle it'll be
nice to have him here instead of going
to Seattle and it'll be it'll be a good
matchup so I think that talking is you
know I think it's always a two-way
street in the conversation the talking
thing we played against German before
and I think I got a lot of respect for
him I've met him a few times off the
field through the NFLPA stuff and it's
one of the things like if you play with
respect towards one another I think the
game will be clean and very competitive
but obviously if I start talking which I
don't it'll be a different thing how do
you know when Aaron Rodgers is mad at
you well sometimes I look some actions
but a lot of times you know if you
screwed up will be mad at you but that's
a great thing to be honest with you he
holds us to very high standards I think
it makes us as receivers and as an
offense elevator
came to his level which is extremely
high if it's in meeting rooms the way he
asked questions to make sure we're on
the same page with him and started
thinking the same way he does its own
practice and then taking it to the
practice field and make sure we're
executing and especially if we've
discussed something in a meeting and to
make sure we carry that over and into
the execution practice because that
gives him the confidence going into a
game that he can rely on us to make the
play are you allowed to be mad at him
absolutely after nine years I've gained
some credibility to give him I don't
know about Matt I'll take that back i'm
a [ __ ] me mad at him does anyone that
has to throw me the ball somo need to be
on guitars but i can razz him a little
bit on different things so especially if
i happen to be correct and he might be a
little off do you buy him a Christmas
gift I have not we'll see how the next
couple weeks ago if i'ma Christmas give
10 have you bought him one before and
he's he bought you one yes I think both
ways I don't ask what it was because I
don't really so something really
meaningful to you absolutely it would
probably meant a lot to the heart so uh
well congrats so far on the season now
six and six and the Seahawks coming to
town Geordie thanks for joining us no
problem thanks admin all right Jordy
Nelson the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience
[Music]